the last part of a dying corpse
that's where Radiohead's thom yorke
called the music streaming service
Spotify see the fart is Spotify and the
dying corpse is the rapidly changing
music industry York said this because he
and many other musicians aren't happy
about online music streaming and how it
doesn't pay much but not everyone's
against it I talked to ok Go's Damien
Coolidge whose band has famously
embraced the online music landscape to
connect with their fans streaming is
clearly how people want to engage with
music these days but you know the
royalties that come from streaming
services are famously
really not a lot to live on things have
changed a lot since the 90s back when I
was playing Biggie Smalls on my discman
remember in 1998 the music industry was
bumpin making more than ever most of the
profit was from CD and record sales but
since those glory days the industry has
continuously shrunk free pirated music
became the norm once we could
legitimately download music via iTunes
we embrace the digital and never looked
back today it's all about streaming
streaming services are popping up
everywhere from Jay Z's premium
subscription service to Apple's new
venture but the music industry as we
know it is now worth half of what it
used to be album sales account for less
than half of the profits the same amount
as digital sales this is why musicians
are taking a hit and they're taking it
out on Spotify Spotify payment service
is complicated but it works like this
every month
Spotify gives 70% of their monthly
revenue to labels and publishers the
more that label songs are streamed the
larger the slice of that 70% they get so
an unnamed indie album Bank $3,000 in
July of 2013 while a global hit album
made 400,000 dollars just from streams
what the artist ends up getting depends
on their contract with their label when
all is said and done most artists end up
making a fraction of a penny for every
song streamed now if you're Taylor Swift
that adds up
she made half a million just from
Spotify in 2014 but it wasn't enough for
T Swift she removed her albums from the
streaming service last year saying she
didn't want to be part of Spotify his
experiment that didn't compensate
artists fairly Spotify says their
service could bring the industry back to
its heyday with more paid subscribers in
1999 the average consumer spent $64 on
music annually today
Spotify dearly subscription costs double
that for access to virtually all the
music in the world except for Taylor
Swift Goulash from okaygo says that with
streaming fans have easy access to their
music so they live with it you're
cutting your own foot off to not have
your music where people listen to music
so to not be on Spotify to not be on
YouTube you're basically removing
yourself from the cultural dialogue okay
so you stream your music you're part of
the cultural dialogue but how do bands
like okay go make their money instead of
relying on old-school album sales okay
go have to get creative
they make famously quirky YouTube videos
which in turn leads to a fan base that
buys merchandise and goes to concerts
which in turn makes advertisers and
sponsors want to work with them and
Coolidge says that thanks to streaming
services smaller bands now have the same
opportunity to be successful at least
modestly so when a big star was a big
star in 1970 1980 1998 and 2000 they
were making lots and lots of money
millions and millions and millions of
dollars that's very very hard to come by
these days but there's very few who will
ever get to eat you know who will be
doing the sort of YouTube Michael
Jackson Madonna sized thing ever again
so what do you think about streaming
services are they good for the industry
or the fart of a dying corpse
mmm